Takže budu mluvit o Maházi technice a o tom, proč děláme tyto věci.
A tohle je... nejsem zvyklý mluvit trochu a pak to představovat.
Já nejsem zvyklý na to, abych mluvil tak, že řeknu něco a pak se to přechvádá.
Takže mám obavu, že vždycky zapomenu toho, o čem mluvím.
Tak jsem se napsal nějaké poznánky.
To je první čas, kdy jsem dělal zkušenost pro lidi, kteří mluví o mém jazyku.
Prvé, kdy dávám kurs lidem, kteří nemluví mým jazykem.
Pod nové dobou dělám týden.
Takže když mi uděláte nějaký odpověď, bych byl velmi, velmi vděčný.
Takže první věc je, abyste si určili,
První věcí je ujasnit si, že smysl toho, co děláme, tohoto kurzu, je správný.
Někteří lidé možná přišli pro nějaký psychologický zisk,
nebo pro fyzický nějaký zisk.
Nebo si dokonce můžou myslet, že získají nějaký duchovní zisk.
Zapomeňte na jakoukoliv naději.
Když přijdeš s představěním, tak se tím představěním stane hnubým.
Jestli byste přišli s nějakým očekáváním, tak toto očekávání se stane překážkou.
Jestli, že například nějaká osoba v duchovním životě nezíská to, co očekává, je zklamána.
A jestli, že přišli s nějakým očekáváním,
A jestliže získají to, co očekávali, jsou zaslepení.
Protože jestliže něco očekáváme, tak je to vlastně myšlenka, představa, kterou promítáme do budoucnosti.
Takže to, co získáme, je pouze to, co jsme si promítili do budoucnosti nebo co jsme získali z minulosti.
Zapomeňte na několik očekávání.
Je to očekávání,
Mnohem důležitější je určitá zručnost nebo zdatnost v meditaci, protože
Umění meditace nám umožňuje žít absolutně v přítomnosti.
A tohle se týká speciálně meditačního kurzu.
A všechny techniky, které Mahasi vyvinul, jsou právě pro tento účel.
Jiný způsob, jak se můžeme podívat na to, co děláme, je, že chceme znovu objevit čistotu
My děláme chybu, když si myslíme, že naše intuitivní inteligence je totéž co myšlenka.
To je vše o tom,
stoping the mind from thinking and imagining.
Právě proto všechny vypisané techniky, nejenom tato, je o zastavení myšlení.
Další chybou je,
proměníme techniku v mystickou praxi.
Technika sama o sobě nic čeho nedosahne.
Můžete stále udržovat myšlenku na věčnosti.
Nic se nezapadne.
Takže technika je jen způsob vytvoření inteligence.
Takže se musíme věnovat pouze té technice, aby se nám ta technika stala obsesí.
A když říkáme, abychom viděli věci více jasněji, myslíme, abychom viděli věci z těchto tří výpočetů, z těchto tří výpočetů.
Myslíme, abychom viděli věci z těchto tří výpočetů.
Tím na mysli pohlednout, vidět třemi způsoby.
Tyto tři způsoby jsou třemi charakteristikami existence.
První je jednou, že
nahlednutí toho, že věci jaksi vystávají a odcházejí.
Druhou věcí je, že vše, když to vystává a odchází, nemohu být, že to nemohu být já.
A z psychologického pohledu je to vlastně nahlednutí toho, jak vytváříme utrpení naší mysli.
Tím, že máme chybný vztah k věcem, které vystávají a odchází.
K tomu se vrátím více v detailech při příští řeči.
Dnes chci pouze zdůraznit důvody, proč musíme dělat tyto techniky.
vymyslel techniky na všechno, co děláme během dne.
Techniky na... Je to vlastně takový...
Ta technika takovým nástrojem
Jak se můžeme na ně dívat?
Jestliže myslíme na označování, označování je myšlení.
Ale používáme myšlení, aby se neznačovalo.
Takže je to vlastně způsob, jak se používá myšlení na zastavení myšlení.
Nejdříve musíme zastavit mysl, aby myslela na věci.
Aby nemyslela na věci.
Dobře.
Dobře poté.
Tak?
Tak.
Jsou to dvě věci, jak může mysl na něco myslet.
Jedna je
velmi nedovedná, nešikovná.
A ta druhá není tak nešikovná.
Ta, která je velmi nešikovná, je, jestliže necháme mysl se touhlet.
Takže když se probudíme ze sná, nějaké představy, fantazie, takže nejdříve to musíme označit, jako třeba nějaké dohadování, pánování,
A pak to musíme dělat ještě po druhé, abychom opravdu rozpoznali, co mysl dělá.
No plánování, plánování.
A pak se vrátíme k dechu.
Když se vrátíte k dechu, můžete pociťovat vzrušení týkající se plánování.
A tímto způsobem se dostaneme zpátky ne k dechu, ale k tomu vzrušení z toho.
Jestli, že to neuděláte, tak se nedíváte na to, co způsobilo, že se mysl toulá.
A je to jako závod za
A je to takový motor za vaší mysl.
Takže je to vlastně jako vstoupání, klesání a měne to jenom jeden okamžik, jednu nanosekundu.
A motor se rozběhne a už letíte.
A, vidíte?
Když se tady sedím a vidíte, že vznikne... O!
Věříte, věříte.
Tak se věříte, věříte, vidím, OK.
When I come back to the breath, I feel the anxiety.
Here, I stay here, with the anxiety.
I let the anxiety express itself.
When the anxiety has expressed itself, no more thinking, no more worrying.
Jestliže ta úzkost se neprojedí, tak už žádné další myšlení, žádné další obavy.
Takže toto označování musí být velmi osobozující.
Musí to být inteligentní označování.
V konce něco jako je dech.
V konce když říkám stoupání a klesání, tak to cítím.
Takže toto jméno je pojmenování.
že toto slovo zaměřuje moji pozornost na objekt.
Ale musím si být jistý, že to slovo je za mým pohledem, za mým díváním.
A chci ten počitek cítit.
Já chci intimně zakoušet mé věnu.
Když to slovo je příliš přede mnou, tak mě to neumožní vnímat ten pocit.
Takže musíme to používat významně.
Takže se to musí využívat moudře.
Jestliže si označíte úzkost, tak jsem řekl úzkost, úzkost, ale moje představování je na cestu, na textu úzkosti.
Takže můj požit mají pozornost, je směrem, na ký máme dojem a pocit slova, jaksi strukturu té úzkosti.
Je to jako klošt.
Můžu vidět klošt, ale musím to cítit.
Teď vím, že tohle je klošt, tohle je tělo.
Stejně jako látka, tak můžeme ji cítit, že toto je něco nám bavlná.
Že to slovo nám pouze umožňuje se dostat blíže k tomu objektu.
Musí být osobozující, inteligentní a musí nám to umožnit cítit a vnímat.
A musíme to dělat nepřetržitě.
Takže se to musí stát zvykostí v mysli, zvykem dávat pozor, dávat pozor.
A to vyžaduje úsví.
A můžete také zlenivě.
Můžete cvičit mysl, aby udělal cokoliv.
To můžete říct stoupání, klesání, dotýkání.
A pokud jdete do Acapulco, když se vrátíte, je vaše mysl stoupání, klesání, dotýkání.
Je to jako když se představíte,
Stejně jako když přecházíte ulici, vaše pozornost je směrem k dopravě.
Nemyslíte na své nohy.
Takže to označování se může stát užitečným zvykem.
Takže to označování
že to musí o tom označit a vnímat to, co skutečně zažíváte.
Dobrá věc ohledně označování je, že vytváří
Předtím bychom si mohli říct, já jsem zlobený, já jsem úzkostný.
Když si tady sedím, říkám, tam je zlobení, tam je úzkostný.
A když sedíme, tak můžeme říct, tak tamhle je zloba, tamhle je úzkost.
Tam je radost, tam je láska.
Ne já, ne ne.
Předtím jsem mohl říct, moje koleno mě bolí.
Ale v mojej meditaci teď vidím,
A meditaci mohu říct, tak tam je bolest v tom kolení.
Ne já.
Jakmile mám tu jasnou objektivitu,
Můj inteligence je osvobozená od zaslepenosti.
A proto se můj inteligence může vidět více jasně,
A proto může vidět jasný to, co zaklouším.
Takže mojí reakcí na
kolenu, na bolest v koleni, je, jak si ji odstrčím, budu dát ji pryč.
Jestliže neodejde, tak se mi chce pohnout s kolenem, s mojí, zase s nohou.
Takže jsem stále ve stavu
Now, if I experience the pain as not me, not mine, then I don't have that reaction.
And so I can investigate more clearly
Takže mohu zkoumat jasněji.
A jestli že jdu do té bolesti, tak co naleznu?
Trošku tepla.
Trošku tlaku.
Co to je za problém?
A teď musí teda být opatrný.
My se nesnažíme zbavit bolestí.
To je ztracená bitva.
Bolest námi bude do hořkého konce.
A jakmile se bolest stane tak nesnesitelná, aby jsme zůstali klidní,
tak pak změňte polohu.
Nás zajímá náš vztah k bolestí, protože chceme vědět, jestli je bolest utrpením, ale nebude to můj vztah, mé vztahování k bolestí, které je utrpením.
Takže můžete slyšet, že ta slova jako značování pomáhají vytvořit tu zdálenost, tu distancu.
Stejně jako ze svědění.
Tak se podívejte.
Hytčení, hytčení, hytčení.
Kdyby jste věděli, kdyby jste se vytvořili.
Když přestanete reagovat, tak prostě jenom si jít.
Řekněte, že použijete označování ve velmi osobuzícím, inteligentním způsobem,
Druhou věcí je označovat záměr.
Takže nejdříve musíme pochopit úlohu
vše, co se stane v mysli, začíná záměrem.
Je třeba to, jak jsem vzdal takovou ruku,
kdyby jsem to nezamýšlel, tak tam musel být záměr.
Kdyby byl naprosto přítomnost jako dobrý meditující, tak bych si toho záměru všiml.
Takže mě neberte jako váš příklad.
A jestliže budeme označovat naše záměry, budeme mnohem více v přítomném okamžiku.
Jestliže se ten záměr objeví, tak se můžeme rozhodnout,
Když jsme si schopni ten záměr uvědomit, tak právě máme volbu, jestli je to až prospešný nebo neprospešný.
Přešlo tam slovo skilful v tomto případě.
Skilful je jako zručný.
Wholesome, unwholesome, prospešný nebo neprospešný.
A také virtuosní nebo nevirtuosní.
Jestli je to cnostný nebo necnostný.
A tak můžeme představit, co musíme dělat.
Můžeme se teda rozhodnout, co bychom mohli udělat.
Někdy při naší meditaci můžeme se cítit velmi neklidní.
A jestliže neudržíte tu velmi jasnou pozornost, tak nezachytíte ten záměr.
A budete překvapeni, když se přistínete, že jdete ven ze dveří.
Poznačování záměru je také způsob, jak se zpomalit.
A důvod, proč se zpomalit, je, abychom mohli vidět jasněji.
Jestliže si třeba představíte filmy o přírodě, když jste třeba viděli film tisíckrát zpomalenej, který představuje žabý jazyk,
Viděli jste něco úžasného.
Jaká část jazyku se myslíte, že chytne mouhu?
To bylo pro mě velké překvapení.
Nikdo by to neviděl, lidský oč by to neviděl, ale film, který to způsobilo 1000x.
Vždycky by se to nevšimlo, jen ten film, který šel tisíckrát pomaly.
Tak tělo a mysl mají dvojitou zpětnou vazbu.
Čím pomalej fyzicky jdete, tím pomalej jde mysl.
Čím jde pomalej mysl, tím jde i tělo.
Maháze even talked about going as slow as a snail.
If we can go very slow, we'll see the intention, the thought.
In the morning, when the bell goes to wake up, if your awareness is very bright, very sharp,
když je vaše pozornost velmi ostrá, uvidíte, ucítíte doslova tukání nebo doteky toho zvonku na váš bubínek.
Only then does the mind take it in and create a sound.
pak to převezme mysl a vytvoří ten zvuk.
Až potom to mysl označí zas zvon.
Až potom tomu mysl dá význam.
Stále.
Až potom to já rozpozná, že
Já musím stát.
Takže začít tento proces je začít vědět, jak vytváříme tento svět.
A my jsme specificky cítili, proč jsme vytvořili svět, který není
A nás obzvláště zajímá, proč jsme vytvořili svět, který není už spokojný.
Budha řekl o sobě nebo o Nirváni, že je tam spokojenost a štěstí, radost.
Tak proč nejsme takoví?
Proč nejsme takoví?
Jestliže nebudete tohleto vidět na konci těchto šestý dnů.
Jestliže to teď nevíte, na konci šestý dnů to budete vidět.
Let me just give you one or two examples.
So for instance, brushing your teeth.
Taste the toothpaste.
When was the last time you tasted the toothpaste?
What does the brush feel like against your teeth?
Take for instance opening a door.
To je otvírání dveří.
Jaký je to pocit?
Kolik energie neskutečnosti potřebujete k otevření dveří?
Kromě toho, že tím teda jenom tak prorazíme těma dveřma, jako my to děláme běžně.
Když jste se zkoušel, když jste se zkoušel, když jste se zkoušel, když jste se zkoušel, když jste se zkoušel,
Zakoušeli jste vaše nohy, když jdete nahoru po schodech.
Dotek zábradlí ve vaší ruce.
Musíme jít až úplně domů na základ těch počítků, abychom vyjasnili inteligenci.
Je to základu toho počítkového, smyslového světa, kde vytváříme náš emoční život a myšlenkový život.
Tím, že se dostaneme k základním věmům, aby jsme zakusili ten základní věm, početek, musíme vyčistit mysl od všech konceptuálních myšlení.
Všechny koncepty jsou minulostí.
And we shall investigate more of that when we come to eating tomorrow.
Okay, so tomorrow we will have group interviews and any problems we can discuss there.
Zítra budeme mít skupinové rozhovory a tam můžeme problémy diskutovat.
A závěrčná žádost?
Nesnišujte techniky.
Je to matoucí pro vás a matoucí pro mě.
Můžu vám dát takový divoký příklad.
A meditující si mi stále stěžoval, že se nemůže soustředit.
Tak jsem mu řekl, že má dělat to a dáme to.
Nic nekomohlo.
Když jsem si všiml, že nedělá meditaci v hůzi, jsem se ptal, co dělal.
Řekl, že šel do krajiny a mluvil s ovcemi.
Já jsem říkal, že kdyby jsi mi to řekl, můžu ti pomoci.
Já bych mohl naučit ovce, jak meditovat.
Jsou některé věci, které můžete udělat, které nezáleží na vaší meditaci.
Takže yoga, tai chi, qigong.
Jsou věci, které nenaruší vaší meditaci, jako je tai chi, yoga, qigong?
Pozít si, budu dělat 20 minut qigongu, jestli můžete se ke mně připojit.
tak to je čas, kdy můžete dělat právě yoga a tai chi.
Tak to je čas, kdy můžete dělat právě yoga a tai chi.
Myslím, že to je vše.
Aporát vám chci říct, že smysl naší meditace je objevit pravou kvalitu pozornosti
A intuitivní inteligence.
Pozornost je asi takové otevřené přijímání.
Bez jakého
A intuitivní inteligence je to, co porozumí tomu, co se děje.
I když Buddha ve svých dílech
často používá obě slova.
Jsou vlastně dvěma strany té žemince.
A naší praxí toto týdnu bude vytvořit, co Buddha nazývá pravou pozorností.
Rám bych zakončil den praxí metá, milující laskavosti, dobré vůle.
Kdybyste si přáli překlad toho, co musíte zpívat, tak je to na straně 24.
Během té doby
a nabídněte jim požehnání.
To je pro nás důležité, protože to, co děláme, není jen pro nás.
Děláme to pro prospěch všech bytostí.
Když se změníme pro dobré,
Když se změníme k lepšímu, vyměníme lidi kolem nás.
A ten účinek se šíří dál.
Vzpomněte, když Buddha byl probuzený, jeho první myšlenka byla, kdo si to může naučit.
Tak jeho první myšlenka byla, koho tomu nemohou učit.
Takže s moudrostí soucit vystává přirození.
To neznamená, že tomu nemůžeme trochu pomoct.
A proto jsme v nocí dokončili s trochu láskavostí a
Proto večer zakončíme trochu milující laskavosti a nabídneme všem lidem a cítícím bytostem to, co jsme v naší praxi získali.
Namo tassa bhagavato arahato sambha sambhu dasa Namo tassa bhagavato arahato sambha sambhu dasa Namo tassa bhagavato arahato sambha sambhu dasa
Karáňaňaňaňaňaňaňaňaňaňaňaňaň
Santendrucha nipakocha pagavokule suananugido.
Nacakudamsamacarekenchi jena vinyupale upavadeyum.
Sukhinavake minohantus abesatavantusukitatam.
Je keči panabutati, tasa vatavarava anavasesa, dihava jemahantava, majima rasakamukatula, ditava jevadita, ichadure vasanti avidure, butava sambhavesi vasa, vesatava vantusukhitata,
Napáro parámi kubeta, nati manjata kata činenkenči.
Vyáru sanapati gasanya, nanyamanya sadukani čeja.
Matájatá nijanku tanga, jusa eka putanga nubake.
Ewanpi sababutesu, manasambavaje aparimanam.
Mějteň čas a balokasmi, manasambhavaje apari-manam.
Udanga doca tiriantsa, sampatanga vedanga sapatam.
Títančaran nesinova, sajanova javatasa vigatamido.
Etang satinga diteya, brahmangetang viharam vidamahum.
So všechny bytosti bez tělesných molestí.
Ať jsou všechny bytosti zbaveny mentálního znepoplení.
Ať jsou všechny bytosti osvobozené ze všech svých utrpení.
Ať všechny bytosti žijí v míru a radosti.
A všechny bytosti žijí spolu v míru a harmonii.
A všechny bytosti zažívají mír a oženání nirvány.
Sábej sarta sukita hantu
sábe sáta sukita hontu sábe sáta sukita hontu sádu sádu sádu sádu sábe sáta sukita hontu to znamená, ať jsou všechny bytosti šťastné.
Já to říkám jako teravádový...